pour la sixième fois dans l'histoire
d'angleterre une rennes reçoit la
couronne grande journée pour le monde
britannique qui vit ses plus belles
heures depuis la fin de la guerre partie
de nos clients palace le carrosse
historique on déplace la reine et le duc
d'edimbourg se dirige vers l'abbaye de
westminster entre 2 et d'une foule telle
qu'on ne vit jamais
[Applaudissements]
un million de spectateurs sont en effet
debout sur le passage du cortège la
plupart passé la nuit à leur place mais
la vue du carrosse doré le visage clair
de cette reine de 27 ans qui symbolise
l'avenir britanniques sont une
magnifique récompense
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
devant l'abbaye de westminster où bas
depuis neuf ans dans le coeur du royaume
d'autres foule aussi dense aussi
haletante c'est là dans ce sanctuaire
que se résume l'histoire d'angleterre
c'est là que depuis les plus anciens
sages les souverains reçoivent la
couronne et le sceptre dans ses apparats
médiévale élise avait 2 va être consacré
par la grâce de dieu n du royaume-uni de
l'irlande du nord et des dominions dont
delà des mers
[Musique]
elle s'avance maintenant sous les voûtes
de westmister à leurs ombres dorment
tout ce roi guerrier ou poètes qui
firent tout au long des siècles la
grandeur du nom anglais
lentement entre 2 et formés par les
délégués de 72 nations les princes des
plus vieilles familles d'europe les
rachats de l'inde les rois d'afrique et
l'échec d'arabie elle marche vers le
sanctuaire
[Musique]
au premier rang le duc d'edimbourg au
centre du coeur le trône antique de
saint-édouard sur lequel furent
couronnés tous les rois d'angleterre est
sur un rythme étrangement lent dans ce
décor coloré où les rois d'arn les
écuyers les chambellans et les pages
s'anime comme les personnages d'une
tapisserie du moyen-âge commencent les
cérémonies qui font d'une souveraine
désigné par les loin une reine marquée
du signe divin
m
sur l'autel les insignes du pouvoir
resplendissent
tout près des ducs aux royaux la
reine-mère à la tribune royale garde
près d'elle le petit prince charles le
futur ou un
instant solennel approche on devait la
reine de la rome impériale et de la
ceinture d'or la voici prête à recevoir
les insignes du pouvoir
l'archevêque de canterbury l'urml epide
l'état symbole de sa juridiction
temporel dont elle ne devra user qu'eux
pour défendre les opprimés selon la
formule sacramentelle
à
le globe qui s'accompagne des mots
prenez ce glande et rappelez vous que le
monde est soumis à dieu notre seigneur
le sépare la coin symbole de la justice
et le sceptre à la colombe symbole de la
miséricorde
et voici l'instant suprême
l'archevêque de canterbury prend la
couronne de saint-édouard sur laquelle
étincelles plus de 1000 pierres
précieuses ils élèvent à la vue de tous
et la pose sur cette tête de 27 ans à ce
moment tous les pères se couvre de leur
couronne médiévale
spectacle étonnant qui veut qu'à
l'époque atomique les rennes est encore
comme en l'an 1000
[Musique]
à cette souveraine couronné à cette
jeune femme devenue le symbole émouvant
de l'angleterre de tous les temps les
pères d'angleterre vont faire leur
serment de suggestions et de fidélité
quittant le trône de saint-édouard et le
gag à pas lent le trône d'état sur
lequel elle recevra la promesse des
grands de son royaume
[Applaudissements]
et le premier le premier gentilhomme du
royaume le duc d'edimbourg s'avance mari
d'elisabeth ils savent où le premier
sujet de sa souveraine
sans couronne à genoux les mains jointes
rentrer les mclaren il prononce les mots
rituel je suis votre homme lige d'un
mais de coeur et c'est toute l'image des
décomptes de chevalerie qui remonte tout
d'un coup du fonds des siècles
[Musique]
c'est fini au milieu des vivats et
dépend par le cortège s'avance pour la
38e fois le vieux décor de westminster a
vu la couronne descendre sur une terre
précédé des porte étendards parmi
lesquels le maréchal montgomery porte
les couleurs royal précédé des chefs des
gouvernements alliés à la couronne venus
d'ottawa de colombo du cap de karachi ou
de canberra dont 108 stone churchill
ferment la marche la reine regagne son
carrosse de conte de fées
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
dehors le ciel gris d'une journée
pluvieuse mais aussi un peuple qui crie
sa joie de riffs mister à pikine yom un
défilé long de 3 km passe entre 3
millions de spectateurs enthousiastes
parade fantastique où se rencontrent
toutes les couleurs tous les uniformes
tous les climats et tous les âges et qui
forment comme le résumé prestigieux des
fastes du monde britannique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
devant buckingham la foule le rond les
barrages
dans ce visage étrangement jeunes que
coiffe une lourde couronne que
cherche-t-il ce peuple est train d'une
émotion singulière
l'avenir de l'angleterre
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]